do quit on the play Dives across and I don't
think people realize how brilliant this save
is out front Sharon goich had a point blank
chance and it's deflected by Guston and then
off the post well lindol wants that one back now
he trying to De feed Sharon goich and Guston says
no dice Tyler tley twice led oh here's a terrible
giveaway and a glove save on Eric Halla now holla
thought he had a goal and John Gibson just robbed
him with the left hand now Meer blast kick save
Ned out on the rebound poot shot doesn't go
a sprawling save so athletic John Gibson you
know he quit on the play Dives across takes that
second rebound in the chest Conor McDavid McDavid
looks shoots M brosi the save and then he made a
spectacular stop after that there's that second
glove hand save on Ryan nen Hopkins the quick
shot by McDavid juicy rebound and stays with
the second one by Newen Hopkins he thought that
was in the net Evan Bard comes in shot right on
there Rebound bosski with a stunning stop
there stretching out with the right P buard
gets the shot through off the toe and then the
extension push off the left reach with the right
PA now Johansson comes up with it plays it off
to the side and what a diving leaping grab by
McKenzie Blackwood and you watch blackwood's
head he's going to be looking to see who could
be available as he locks in and he gets the
glove on it dropped it off Detroit Terry
pass in front save quick with a great save oh
Jonathan Quick what an athletic play how about
this one two three by Jonathan Quick I guess
that's what they call Jonathan Quick compete
is that what they call that ostron to the the
front save me rebound and soken shut it down
sokin had to Lunge to his left to stop that
one with Morgan geeki hunting for the first
goal of the night what a stop from sokin still
scoreless IL he's got no business making this
safe back to gas s shot oh whoo stopped at
rebound oh and set wide how do you oh there how
he miss the net he got the blade of the stick on
a wide open net it's should have been two nothing
and Terry's looking at it going seriously holy
smoke show control in on venar sto by lar the
old scorpion works that is called second effort
period and a great second effort they don't ask
how oh that's beautiful look at that Nelson
Has PA Mar has Ang ball they go across for
pal Mary and Lena saw mark an incredible SA now
Mary ends up with the opportunity what a great
read by lenus olark and he has to stay deep he
has to stay deep in his net to make that save
can he do it again Paso save rebound no the skate
blade of allar wow what a stop as Jo gets a great
chance you saying wow what a Sav by Omar and then
Holstrom gets the rebound with most of the net
available after it inde Brock besser a
Tapper and a save by moric and another
brilliant save on the rebound by hoglander
hogland oh my goodness holy jumping what a
save this is and I don't think people realize
how brilliant this save is they're seeing it
now on the Jumbotron and they are on their
feet recognizing morazi's Brilliance right
there oh want to save by goria terrific glove
save on zerin comes across gets that right in
the glove see the split Steven Stan shoots
stopped by lar re great save lar a point
well not the stop of the night as points that
close to a second of the game of lar with the
answer with that terrific glove stop the Stick
of ptil hitot tarz and B linoln stretches out
and robs John tarz includ good pressure in and
how about the save of M leans here tamarus tries
to get around the leg here's a chance for
Fox out the net oh a save good recovery by
dostall to get back and just spread out oh he
was way out of the net way out now he's going
to push off and get all the way back over does
the splits that's a beautiful save looking in
front to Stone saely by he was spread out and
got the right pad on it he's going to stone
stone right there he get two opportunities
the third one he puts off the side of the
net Deon does a nice job staying with it he
gets a little help Alex top right in the net